so right now following leading cause of
death
for people ages 1 to 44. okay they call
this the youth younger ages 1 to 44.
cancer heart disease homicide Motor
Vehicles suicide and drug overdose
historically in 1980 up until 2000 drug
overdose was last by mile this data just
came out by the CDC I want you to take a
look at this can you put this up
take a look at this you guys on what's
happened okay look at HIV in 86 it goes
up boom flat line it's pretty much gone
they're not even tracking the stats
anymore like they did before
heart disease going slightly lower you
got cancer is around homicide is there
accidents is gone lower look at these
poisoning drug overdoses and the number
000 and climbing
fifty thousand and climbing okay so when
you see this what do you think about Tom
my mind goes to a couple different
places where do you go when you see a
stat like this as a parent this scares
the hell out of me and and there is a
story behind the story here that
fentanyl is being intentionally shipped
to this country in illegal drugs and the
nation's children are getting a hold of
it and they're just they're you know
they're dropping a tab partying and it
turns out that it's laced and that's
what's going on here and it's horrifying
and I don't think anybody wants to talk
about it when I see like this it just
underlines just why I've been so
proactive so early with my kids because
the internet and everything that's
happened so much earlier in life getting
a hold of my girls before my parents got
a hold of me because of what's out there
and realizing it only takes one man we
used to talk in the late 80s you look at
HIV there and so I graduated
um high school early 80s and so back
then take a look at the HIV line my
parents used to say you got to be
careful it only takes one time and you
can get HIV it only takes one time HIV
and it was considered a death sentence
back then before AZT protease Inhibitors
and all the things that build the
Cocktails so that people can live like
Magic Johnson many many many decades
this it only takes one and you're out
and it just scares the hell out of me
and Pat I actually lost uh my mom knows
I lost two friends uh mom about a year
ago my friend uh fukuan and my boy Rico
they were just hanging out they trusted
this girl they were just at a house you
know L.A they're chilling uh one of them
had his girlfriend with him apparently
they all did just one little you know
little bit of cocaine all three dead the
other girl OD'd but she survived and
this is and I think we talked about last
podcast Pat this is and you said because
I'm yeah some of it's coming over the
Border but one of the main ones that
fentanyl is coming in here is from China
okay so China's winning bro I mean we
owe them all this money they're making
not the money that they owe us but uh we
owe them they're making money on the
Fentanyl and they're killing Americans
so it's it's a win-win for them and no
but that's that's not a big deal to
people you're a great uncle you spend a
lot of time with your not a great uncle
meaning he's got you know
very good yeah not an old Uncle great
uncle Robin and you have a nephew what
do you think about this story well I
think there's uh um I too have lost some
friends in Miami that have
overdosed Rob can you pull up that that
graph I think there's a few things going
on right here you could see that it
really boom takes off around 2010 right
which was right around the time when
social media started blowing up so
you know the the the the you know what's
that what's the term when you um can you
put out the chart for the audience Jorge
or Eric go ahead what's the term when
you uh the fear of missing out fomo I
think social media has a major pro has
been a major factor at this if you can
just you know what do they say like the
most dangerous people in the world right
now are lonely sexless men sitting in
their basement so to speak and if you
are just home on your phone and everyone
out there is living their best life and
you just buy yourself and you're a 16
year old kid 22 year old kid 24 year old
guy whatever it is and everyone's having
a great time and you're home alone and
you're doing some sort of drug by
yourself I think social media has led to
that and then I think what is even worse
as you can see was trending upward and
then since covet it is just skyrocketed
and that's sad because what you don't
hear people saying is get the hell out
of your house exercise go hang out with
friends be a human get out there like
thank you and you don't hear people
talking about that you hear people
saying you know take the pill take the
jab get you know get surgery quick fixes
no like you know one of the things that
I give you major credit for Lincoln on
leadership is no we're not all [__]
working remote we're going to be around
each other and we're going to be amongst
each other we're going to create a
culture we're going to have teamwork
we're going to hold each other
accountable and I think from for for
young people out there there's just this
you know
lack of friendship and a lack of
togetherness and even if it's in school
that's fine but then you go home and you
go on your iPad and you're alone and you
don't know what kind of thoughts are
going through people's heads when
they're home alone in front of a screen
and I think it's incumbent on parents I
think it's incumbent on teachers I think
it's a comment on friends I think it's a
comment on family to just check in on
people that you think may have a problem
and even kids that you don't have a
problem and I think this is a this is an
American issue that we need to to tackle
it's such I think that's a great point
I'm going to make one one quick point
out to cut you off I I like that they're
using poisoning because I don't think
your friends Adam like mine they didn't
OD they didn't sit there and shoot up my
friends were poisoned because this girl
got whatever they got the drugs from
whoever that [__] was poison because
they weren't sitting there they did one
bump of cocaine and they were all dead
because fentanyl the the amount that
fits on the top of this can kill your
ass so I I don't think it's okay I would
like to know because I've lost friends
for from overdoses right they we know
that they had problems they were
partying and and we all I mean show of
hands if you know somebody that has
passed away from some sort of Overdose
this is an American problem that we're
all dealing with so the poisoning I
think is one small percentage of it I'd
like to know the stats on that I don't
know too many people are like I don't do
any drugs boom I died I think a lot of
it is like this Collective drip drip
drip drip drip drip drip boom now you've
just overdosed so it's it's a sad
situation that we need to talk would you
bring up about social media I think is
really important the the irony of the
election of Donald Trump happened at a
time remember we were talking about
Facebook we were worried about the
addiction of kids and then as soon as
the election happened we were worried
about Facebook about Russian
interference and everything like that
there is a dialogue that was going on in
the United States about how kids were
being hyper addicted to social media and
how there were whistleblowers inside
Facebook that said you know we've kind
of programmed it this way to keep you in
to keep you chasing likes yep that your
your self worth was I was connected to
your social measurement measured by how
many people like you you had to be
crazier more outrageous the makeup
whatever you were doing had to be more
more to get the likes and that kind of
stopped and went to the side and then we
had hearings on okay you social media
guys how do we get the orange man
elected what happened here and it moved
to that and you know um I went to a
movie recently and both my wife and I
anybody see the Dove soap commercial in
the movie where the the ladies talking
to her daughter and they're talking
about the risk of social media and
everything like that I think I think
this dialogue has to consider be
considered because I could call that the
Zuckerberg line because why are you
taking the drugs why are you dropping
these tabs what is so necessary about
partying and doing it you're getting
poisoned by the drug you're taking but
why is it that you're turning to do that
and I happen to think social media is a
big part of it so so a social dilemma is
a documentary that how many guys watched
the documentary social dilemma a lot of
people thinking talking all this stuff
but you know I will tell you this
yesterday we're doing a elite Mastermind
and one of my favorite guys you guys
know who he is uh uh he's asking
questions saying you know I'm afraid uh
this happening to me I'm afraid of
making this decision what if this goes
wrong what if at 70 I work hard I build
my company but nothing happens and this
this this that
I said why is it for the last three
years every time I talk to you you
always come from a place of fear and he
says I don't know I said uh do you
believe in God he says Ah
as he says I'm in uh you know I'm in
this country where it's the number one
country in the world for atheists I said
okay I said do you go to church he says
I don't go to church I said what do you
think about faith he says no not really
I'm not big on it so I said I'm going to
recommend a book to you I don't know if
you're going to read it or not but I
highly recommend you read it I said let
me tell you what I noticed that I want
you to be thinking about he says because
when I watch you I watch how hard you
work and how many things you're doing
but how come you don't seem stressed out
and you're just kind of enjoying the
process you got a wife you got four kids
you're running these businesses all this
other stuff how come you don't seem like
you're overwhelmed like you're just kind
of going with the flow I said dude it's
only because I truly believe someone's
got my back and by the way I'm not here
you you will rarely ever hear me talk
about my faith but I think there's a few
different things peer pressure is a good
thing if it's the right peers peer
pressure is a bad thing if it's the
right wrong peers we need better peer
pressure the right peer pressure forces
you to make better decisions because you
don't want to let down to people in your
community there was a form of a peer
pressure this morning when we were
having a meeting back there it's between
us but you know exactly what I'm talking
about peer pressure is a good thing I
think people need to start spending more
time in churches I think whatever you
practice go do it this goes back to the
clip we talked about with Robert Downey
Jr and Mel Gibson the other day about
the fact that how many guys I've seen
the whole Robert Downey Jr Mel Gibson
where he says
the reason why I brought Mel Gibson here
is because years ago when I had nothing
going on and I was an alcoholic Mel came
up to me and well I couldn't pay the
bills I couldn't pay rent I couldn't we
can't play this because the music I
couldn't do this I couldn't do that he
gave me a job and that job put a roof
over my head and I asked him I said how
can I ever pay you back because you know
Robert Downey Jr is not blowing up he
says he told me go find your faith he
says Mel never told me which Faith he
just said go find your faith whatever
that Faith may be and it starts with
responsibility Robert Downey Jr is
happily married quiet low-key you don't
see him at the clubs any of that stuff
and to me one of my favorite I don't
know if you guys like this guy I love
Robert Downey Jr's acting how he is a
story Underdog Redemption any of that
stuff and he says later on when you go
through this pass this down to somebody
else so a lot of these drugs that you're
seeing we can blame social media we
can't blame all of that stuff people are
uncomfortable talking about taking
people to go to church going to a
faith-based and environment and having
the right people around you the better
the peers you have around you better
Community you're a part of you're going
to perform better when I when I was
around other guys and at one point I was
a bodyguard most people don't know the
story if you really know the story you
really follow our contents I've only
told the story one other time as a
bodyguard for a Colombian guy
and he didn't sell baseball cards you
know what I'm saying so so one day we go
out and I'm hanging out with these guys
first of all we're having a Time Of Our
Lives just so you know because
Colombians they know how to party but
this Colombian guy was a very well-known
Colombian guy in L.A
you don't need to know who he is but he
was a very built no Colombian guy and I
was a very well-known you know
tough guy tough guy not a tough guy but
I would say I was a very well-known guy
that I could handle myself in pressure
type situations however way you wanted
to find that right so we meet we go out
all of a sudden I'm on a uh yacht and
Marina Del Rey and there's a mountain of
this White Mountain you know if you want
to call whatever you want to call this
white mountain and he says we have to
this guy owes us a hundred thousand
dollars
I'm like so that's why I'm here yeah
great okay fantastic
so obviously we collect a hundred
thousand dollars but here's the point
while this whole thing is over with I go
back in the car and I know what I did
that night like with the people were
hanging out with I'm like dude this is
the wrong crowd to be around do you know
if I stay in that Community for two more
weeks three more weeks the guy goes to
jail by the way if I'm there for three
more months nobody came in I don't have
my four kids I will never meet Patrick I
will never meet Dylan I will never meet
Senna I will never meet Brooklyn I will
never meet these wonderful people in my
life I will never meet Mario I would
never meet Tom I wouldn't
I would never you're one stupid decision
away if you have the wrong pressure
pierced around you you get in the right
environment where they're pressuring you
to improve your marriage pressuring you
to be a better father pressuring you to
be a better friend pressuring you to be
a better person financially then one day
you wake up and you're like okay great
this is fantastic we've done okay we're
gonna make mistakes you're gonna screw
up this doesn't mean just because you
have faith you're going to walk on water
but I think we need more of that today
that's all I'm talking about so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]